hello and welcome to the take with
sophie ridge live at nine here in the
heart of westminster well tonight it is
all about the elections taking place
across the united kingdom tomorrow
thousands of local government seats are
up for grabs and what will undoubtedly
be seen as a referendum on boris
johnson's leadership most crucial of all
could be the vote in northern ireland
where the polls predict the nationalists
could gain the most seats in stormont
for the first time in its history so
there is plenty for us to get stuck into
as we bring you takes from all sides
over the next 60 minutes
well more than 4 000 council seats have
been contested in england every council
seat in scotland hundreds more in wales
plus that potentially historic contest
of course for the northern ireland
assembly
we're going to have some exclusive
polling for this program that was going
to give us an insight into what could
happen and why plus all the analysis
that you need ahead of voting tomorrow
we are going to be joined by all of the
major parties across great britain
including for the conservatives the
education minister michelle doddling for
labour the shadow employment minister
alison mcgovern for the snp treasury
spokesperson alison feuless plus we're
going to speak to the lib dems the
greens and polite cummery and get the
latest from northern ireland take a
breath all that and more coming up on
the take
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening well there are just 10
hours until polls open i'm sure there
are lots of nervous candidates doing a
bit of last-minute campaigning wondering
if it's too late to knock on a door and
no doubt a few nervous party leaders too
converse johnson proved to his party
that he is still an election winner or
there'll be rumblings about his
premiership once again in a couple of
days time and two years into his
leadership will kiss starman make enough
gains to show his party that he's the
man who can lead labour to victory
against the backdrop of a cost of living
crisis meanwhile in scotland the s p
will expect to continue its dominance
and in northern ireland sinn fein could
win a historic first assembly election
well let's have a look now at what will
happen tomorrow
in england
4359 seats are up for grabs including
all of those in london every council
seat in scotland has also been contested
that's
1226 councillors across 32 councils
in northern ireland voters are choosing
mlas for the assembly all 90 seats are
again being contested and the election
is going to decide the next first
minister and finally in wales there are
local council elections too with all
1234 seats in 22 councils being voted on
we can start this evening by hearing
from the conservatives who speak now to
the education minister michelle doddling
thank you for joining us what would a
good night look like for the
conservatives
good evening sophie well we're not
getting into the business of predicting
certain numbers what we are doing is
continuing to focus on knocking on doors
obviously it is as you said a little bit
late now at 9 00 pm but we'll be back
out again tomorrow reminding local
people of what we have on offer
my own finding and experience of
canvassing up and down the country has
really been that this is an election on
local issues most people will be going
to the polls tomorrow voting on potholes
and pavements and which council delivers
that which party will deliver for the
best of them at a council level we know
that conservatives
offer you more for less money and that's
the key message that i would like to
leave voters with today
so are voters actually voting on local
issues or do you hope they're voting on
local issues because it does feel as if
boris johnson might be turning from an
electoral asset into a liability few
would that be ryan
i think my own experience knocking on
doors has been that yes
national issues do come up now and again
but predominantly it is local issues
this is a local election potholes
pavements council tax prices they all
come up much more than the national
issues because at the end of the day
i can't say the party gate word what
kind of national issues
well including that of course um also
including what's going on with kierstama
at the moment including uh the rising uh
cost of inflation and costs that people
are facing all of these come up on the
doorstep but more often than not it's
about local issues because this is a
local election at the end of the day
i just want to read you a leaflet for
a councillor called james brewer now he
is your candidate in burn valley
on his literature he says this thursday
please don't punish local conservatives
for the mistakes made in westminster we
are local and proud of where we live and
like you we want the best for hartlepool
are you worried that some good
councillors are going to end up being
punished for well he describes it as the
mistakes in westminster we know what
he's talking about he's talking about
party gate scandal isn't he
well we are midterm in the election
cycle you know we know that it would be
unusual for a government to triumph home
at this point in that election cycle but
if you look at blair's government he
hemorrhaged thousands of council seats
at this point um so we have to be open
and honest about where we are and uh
obviously council elections are not
taking place across the entire country
at the moment but we will be looking
carefully at those results tomorrow and
they will be based on local issues
predominantly but of course people
consider national issues as well and
we'll see what happens tomorrow yeah
they certainly do
consider national issues inevitably as
you say and it's not just this one
candidate who is trying to distance
himself from westminster and wandsworth
for example margaret thatcher's favorite
council conservative for 44 years
candidates have actually rebranded
themselves on the ballot paper they're
calling themselves the local
conservatives
is boris johnson a bit of an election
liability now
well absolutely not you know we have an
atc majority um which was driven by this
prime minister and achieved by this
prime minister he's an asset not a
liability
um but
i understand why counselors want to put
local conservative they want to
reinforce the message that they care
about local issues they care about
potholes they care about pavements
they're going to be working hard on all
of those things that impact daily life
and not be distracted so it is important
that you put the word local on an
election leave that i don't think that
that symbolizes anything more than that
you say that boris johnson is an asset
you're talking about his atc majority at
the next election does that mean that
whatever happens uh tomorrow whatever
the results are you think he's safe as
leader
absolutely my faith is in boris johnson
as prime minister as i said we are in
midterm of an election cycle
we know that governments particularly
suffer at this point in the election
cycle we've not got council elections
everywhere in fact my own constituency
and in wheelchair we're not having
council elections so it isn't reflective
of the entire picture
how much of an issue do you think a
partygate actually is then how much is
it coming up on the doorstep
honestly would it be coming up as one of
the things but the prime minister has
acknowledged what happened he's taken
full responsibility he's apologized he's
paid the fine and also i'm getting
people on the doorstep saying that
saying what we need to move on i'm
really concerned about the the rising
cost of inflation and how that's
impacting me i'm really concerned about
other issues uh and they need to cut
through as well so that is
not the predominant issue on the
doorstep from my own experience
certainly
it's interesting to hear you say that
you want the cost of living to cut
through as well but because i have to
say like it feels politically that is
dangerous territory for you to say the
least and people really really
struggling you know biggest fall in
living standards potentially for a
generation since records began all the
way back in the 70s
you don't want to be fought on that
either do you
well no what i'm saying is that that is
a topic that comes up on the doorstep
but it's something that the people are
saying they want to cut through because
they want to be talking about those
issues
not just constantly when they turn on
the telly it's always about uh parties
and what's happened in the past they
want to be focusing on what is impacting
them today so it's important as
politicians that we're talking about the
issues that affect our voters day in and
day out i think that's really important
okay
and just finally i know you don't want
to be drawn on you know any numbers or
anything like that um
at the same time there's a few flagship
councils particularly in london isn't
there you know wandsworth westminster
barnet how important is it to hang on to
those councils
but we'll be we've done our very best uh
throughout this campaign to get our
message out there that conservatives can
deliver more for less you know we have a
proven track record especially in those
councils that you've referenced
including wandsworth i'm confident that
when people go and vote tomorrow they
will consider that and we will see what
happens tomorrow
okay thank you very much for being on
the program michelle donalon uh there
thank you
well certainly the conservatives are
there wanting to fight this local
election on local issues we can get
labour's take now on the elections we're
joined now by alison govind she's on the
campaign trail
in the world uh good to have you on the
program alison
we just heard there from the
conservatives what's a good night for
labor
we want to make progress you know we
want labour councillors elected to step
up for their areas and to see
really good quality public services
that's what success will look like you
know we've come a long way over the past
few years and we want to continue that
progress
you say you want to continue the
progress of the last few years and but
certainly it does feel doesn't it that
you know if you look at the uh backdrop
that you're fighting these elections on
you've got boris johnson a prime
minister who's been fined by the police
for breaching covered laws you've got a
cost of living crisis why aren't you
doing better in the polls than you are
sure you should be storming ahead
well let's see what happens when the
results are in but i would say you know
people care deeply about what the
strength of their local communities and
councils are the backbone of their area
so i think every labour councillor
elected will be a very important
champion
you know
up and down the country people want town
centers looked after they want good
quality public services for their
families so that their areas can be
strong and i think therefore every
labour councillor will be a success we
know that the labour party has changed a
lot um under kirsten's leadership over
the past couple of years and on
doorsteps you know we've been hearing
all kinds of troubles that people have
been having whether it's energy bills or
challenges paying for the shopping we
know people are really under pressure
and so that's why we need labour
councillors elected to stand up for them
it's interesting listening to you and
listening to our previous guests it's
almost the same answers that actually
people are voting on local issues like
potholes and for local champions and
concerns about the cost of living do you
not think you need to kind of
differentiate a little bit more
don't get me wrong
the prime minister does get a mention
and not always in complementary terms i
might say
um you know people are angry they're
really angry about how they've been
treated about all of the things that
happened during the pandemic you know
the waste on ppe and
all of the ways in which people feel our
country should have been treated better
by boris johnson as a prime minister and
the disrespect that they feel that he
has shown them people are angry but i
suppose what i also believe is that
labour councillors are the best possible
defense against that they've you know
labor councils show that they can stand
up for people and look after ours and we
saw that again in the pandemic you know
with um
as our mayors
in my area steve rotherham doing a great
job so of course people are deeply angry
with boris johnson but also these
elections really matter because who runs
your council is an important question um
i want to talk to you a little bit about
uh romeo we've spoken a lot about you
know party gay there's an admission uh
by a previous guest uh that partygate
was coming up on the doorstep in
relation to the prime minister
there are these lingering questions
around what happened when kirstama was
out campaigning
in durham at a time when there were
covered restrictions in
place now he says of course no rules
were broken but you know curry for 30
people journalists effectively misled
over whether angela rainer
was there
what actually went on and why does there
seem to be this reluctance by labour for
being straight about what happened
well it was a different time period of
course kids answered those questions
this morning and the main point is boris
johnson has been fined by the police you
know we know that now so we know what's
happened
of course people
want to know that the rules apply to
everyone and they did
and it's a very serious thing what's
happened with the prime minister so i
don't you know i think that the most
important thing
is for
us to accept
what's happened with the prime minister
and
it is coming up on the doorstep as you
said sophie this is an issue
equally in the elections tomorrow i know
lots of people will be thinking about
who their local councillors are and that
they stand up for those services that
they need
you say that you know it's a different
time period so i just want to look at
the legislation on the covered rules you
know at the time of this durham event
you know this is the relevant section
of the rules it says um under
campaigning
the gathering consists of no more than
two people
at least uh one of whom is a campaigner
now there are obviously more than two
people at this event 30 people
reportedly have a curry but there is an
argument that there's an exception to
that and this is the exception that
might apply the gathering is reasonably
necessary for the purposes of
campaigning in an election or a
referendum
you know i guess the question is
is sitting down to have a curry with 30
people
reasonably necessary for the purposes of
campaigning
the as i understand it they were working
all day and took a break for some food
and then the work continued on this
issue has been looked at
and you know boris johnson was issued
with a fine and the police have looked
at this issue and dealt with it
you say that's been looked at but durham
police seem to say that it's still being
looked at we've received a number of
recent communications on the subject
which we're considering
that's from today
yeah i mean that sounds to me like the
response that the police would give i
mean what you know they
are responsible for responding to any
queries as i'm sure they do in a very
professional way
you know
boris johnson has been fined and
this issue has been looked at and the
police are dealing with it and i think
that's you know
in the end that is their job and i'm
sure they will uh do it professionally
okay and then just finally i just want
to have a bit of a look about the kind
of picture of where you're fighting
you're obviously fighting lots in london
where you already have you know a lot of
councils uh a very kind of high
threshold if you like how important is
it going to be for labour to show that
you're not losing ground or you're
perhaps making a bit of progress
in the so-called red wall in those areas
where the conservatives have been eating
into labor heartlands in recent years
well i'm not sure i kind of agree with
this rebel terminology sophie i mean you
know i think that
places in the north of england they're
not all the same they're not just one
big so-called red wall block so i don't
really you know accept that terminology
i think that there's lots of places um
across the country where labour
campaigners have been fighting hard you
mentioned
london in my own area in the world you
know people are out there campaigning
and the idea that somehow the north of
england is just one big block that can
be characterized in that way i'm afraid
i don't agree with uh fair enough uh
alison mcgovern thank you very much for
being on the programme there alison and
we're going to perform the labour party
a little bit later in the programme we
are also going to be talking to the
scottish national party plus the lib
dems the green party and applying to
country as well
but before all that this could be quite
interesting uh we are going to have a
look at some exclusive polling for this
program to find out a bit of a taste
about what could happen uh tomorrow
we're joined now by our deputy political
editor
sam cope sam what have you been looking
at
so we've got the local elections
tomorrow all across the country but
yougov have been doing some modeling for
us based on polling over the last week
telling us what they think about 16 key
council races now you can see that there
are elections all over the united
kingdom for the stormont assembly there
in northern ireland uh you've got all
the councils in scotland out all 32 of
them for the first time since 1997 22
all out again in wales but what's
different about england is that there
are only some other councils in england
they're often urban areas including all
councils out in london so only 146 about
half the councils are out in england now
if you look at what that's the overall
picture so all out across every other
country apart from england now if you
look at just the councils that are up
for election here we start running
through what that looks like actually
the ones that are up for election on
thursday of tomorrow are
by a majority labour 62 uh councils are
held by labour 46 by the conservatives
11 uh libdem 27 and overall control now
the point about showing you this about
the councils that are up for election on
thursday is that you can see that more
of them uh are labor so labour already
doing well where people are going so
harder to make gains much harder to make
gains so now let's look at some of the
calls that yougov tonight are making
let's start in london london one of the
best areas for london you can see
already uh they've got lots of targets
for the concert for the labour party uh
because there are barnett wandsworth
hillingdon and westminster all held by
the conservatives so if you look here at
what yougov say you can see quite a lot
of potential for the labour party they
think that uh wandsworth currently
conservative now leaning labour that
would be a very big result for the
labour party uh they look likely to hold
on to croydon and they could just about
take barnett and westminster which are
both too close to call tonight so this
is big news for labour it looks like
even though they've got this high base
in london they're doing well there are
potential there's potential for labour
to take some of the if you like the
jewels the conservative jewels in london
i mean one's worth for example margaret
thatcher's favorite council i think is
it conservative 44 years or something
that's now according to yougov leading
labour and that would be a great night
for kierstarma if that happened but the
question is can he build on his base in
london he of course himself and london
mp and start to reach out elsewhere in
the country well let's look at what
yougov are making calls about for
councils in the south now at the moment
you've got a mixed pitch you've got no
other cool control and worthing milf and
keys and crawly uh key background of
southampton laboratory battleground
there uh currently concerned held and
hastings uh currently labor and here the
picture
isn't too bad for labour they could make
some gains so they could pick up
southampton southampton is a uh as i say
marginal that often uh flips between the
two major parties that could go labour
but then you look at hastings now
hastings currently under labour control
you have aren't sure aren't absolutely
sure that they're going to hang on to
it's more likely than not they say it's
leading labour but that leaves some uh
wiggle room that would be quite a bad
night if they lost hastings and then
those councils are on no overall control
well not much sign of progress in the
labour direction uh in those key races
and then let's look at the north
and here are yougov's calls for the
north here are three councils held by
label berry hull and called us out in
three currently under no overall control
and let's look at what labour what
yougov says about them you look at this
you've got uh three councils which don't
show the labour policy making great deal
of progress bolton kirkley's we're all
kind of key redwall territory uh and
then barry that is currently controlled
by labour it will probably stay labor
but you gov aren't certain and then hull
now that's another sign that this is a
big danger sign for the labour party
could they end up not keeping control of
hell they've always had a strange kind
of challenge from the lib dems in uh in
hull so it's not a it's not a
traditional northern council uh but then
again calderdale you look at that seat
and it's only leaning labour they're not
certain that laid parts will hold on to
those i guess you look at some of these
names and they're familiar names because
they're marginals in general elections
as well barry for example i mean i
remember you know you and me are always
going to places like barry right because
they've got marginal seats all over the
place and if they are not being shored
up for labour at this stage in the
midterm do you think that's a bit of a
warning sign for a general election or
we're reading too much into it
it is in part but i think what it
underscores is just how complicated
these elections are look it may well be
the case that we come out on friday once
the results are counted and labor have
won possibly hundreds of seats but
because where those seats are and
because they're in urban areas that were
already voting labor and because many of
the councils that we're talking about
well they're only up for election in
thirds rather than the whole council all
out well actually all of that just makes
it harder for the labour party to take
them outright even if they win quite a
lot of seats interesting stuff sam thank
you very much for that exclusive
analysis there you are watching the take
live from westminster it is our local
election special so next up we're going
to be talking to the smp's shadow
chancellor
[Music]
welcome back live to westminster this is
the take well all of the council seats
in scotland are up for grabs tomorrow so
the snp will be hoping to keep its grip
on power at all levels the crucial part
really is for second place between the
conservatives and labor well we're
joined now by the s p's treasury
spokesperson allison fulis thank you for
being with us what's a good night look
like for the snp
good night for us eh so he looks as
though we would take councils that we
don't currently take retain those that
we have already
and take control of councils we're
perhaps we're in coalition at the moment
well people are also going to be looking
at the race for second place uh in
scotland and the conservatives defending
of course a good performance back in
2018 or labour could they overtake them
who's your money on
well certainly the conservatives don't
seem to be doing particularly well in
glasgow they had a little bounce in
glasgow last time around but we're not
detecting that on the doorsteps over the
past few days and going around different
parts of glasgow i've yet to find
anybody that is telling me that they're
voting conservative
so do you think that in that that's part
of the reason you're hoping to make some
of these gains off the back of a poorer
performance from the conservatives
i mean we're making hope to make these
games on the back of a very positive
message that we've got as well um great
manifestos that we have across all 32
different local authorities in scotland
and we're hoping to make gains on the
back of positive messages that we've got
but yes there are people
who are very clearly telling me in the
doorsteps how fed up they are with the
conservatives at westminster with their
behavior
and with the way that they are failing
to tackle the cost of living crisis
you say that you want to you know make
gains at the back of the positive
message from the snp but you haven't
necessarily had the easiest run up to
these elections at the same time have
you
lots of questions of course about this
botched contract to provide two ferries
that ended up running five years late
and
tens of millions of pounds over budget
now i asked nicholas sturgeon about this
on sunday she told me that the
government took the shipyard into public
owned ownership in order that we could
safeguard the future of commercial
shipbuilding on the river clyde and
we've secured that and then she
reiterated that message the same day the
next day sorry saying the ship guard
would effectively gone under without
this contract
but the former owner of that shipyard
jim mccall has now accused nicolas
sturgeon of lying he says that actually
there was no danger of the yard going
under at that time so who's telling the
truth here
well all of that of course is as a
matter of opinion you can guess that
what might have happened had a certain
course of action been taken or not taken
but we did the scottish government did
take the decision that those 400 jobs
and more fundamentally that this
industry on the clyde was really
important and it should be saved
because shipbuilding is important to
scotland we want to invest in that and
it's important that we have those skills
and that we retain those skills in yards
such as ferguson's but nicholas sturgeon
didn't say it was a matter of opinion
did she she said that the shipyard would
have gone under that's a problem isn't
it
i think that if there's a very real case
that you'd be made that it would have
gone under had that action not been
taken
okay
now we spoke a bit earlier that we've
been talking a lot about party gate you
say that you know some of the
dissatisfaction with the conservatives
have come up we spoke a bit earlier in
the programme to alison mcgovern as well
about this event in durham that the
conservatives say show that kierstama
actually breached the lockdown rules as
well some of those covered rules too he
says he didn't conservatives say he did
if you're a bit of a kind of impartial
person in the middle perhaps maybe not
do you think it's muddlingly by the
conservatives or do you think that
kistama has questions to answer
i think it certainly suits the
conservatives to selling mud in the
opposite direction given quite the level
of trouble that they are in they've had
a serving prime minister uh served with
a fine for his behavior for breaking the
covered rules that he set and all
indications would suggest that it's not
going to be the only fine that he
receives for parties and dining streets
for the suitcases of booze that were
pulled into downing street uh during the
course of the pandemic when everybody
else was following the rules and doing
their best to protect their loved ones
so it sets the conservatives certainly
to sling mud on this but um certainly
the people i've been speaking to over
the course of the past week aren't
fooled at all they know the score and
they know what's going on um and i think
the conservatives if they look at
closely at their own uh voters in their
own constituencies they know that too
okay thank you very much for coming on
the program uh today giving your
take on what is happening in scotland
with these elections thank you
you're watching the take we are live in
westminster and up next we're gonna
speaking to be speaking to even even
more parties hoping for votes in
tomorrow's local elections will be
joined by representatives from the lib
dems the greens and pride country as
well
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
you are watching the take
now if you're a regular viewer you will
know that on the tape we usually have a
panel of viewers but
you're falling over there this week
we've got a panel of politicians to
bring you because we continue our focus
on tomorrow's election so now we can
speak to some more parties who are
hoping to make progress tomorrow we're
joined now by christian jardine of the
liberal democrats by
emilia womack who is the deputy leader
of the green party and also by liz
savile roberts of applied comrade hello
to all of you let's start with you first
uh christine shall we christian jody um
what does a good night look like for the
liberal democrats
well good night
this is the same
as it is for everybody else it's more
councillors more councils and and you
know an improved position a reflection
we feel of the increased support we are
seeing across the country um and that
would be that would be a good night for
us let's put the same question to emilia
womack shall we because the greens have
made some progress haven't you in recent
years what would a good night look like
for you
well of course breaking onto new
councils but moving into the opposition
party in many of those in places like
bernie and reading we have the
opportunity to make such good games um
making sure that we are proving as well
that the voices of communities are being
represented and that work that our
counts our candidates have currently
been doing to ensure that they get
elected as councillors is represented
through those big wins last year we won
99 new seats uh we are um
we we won even more councillors in that
interim time between last year and now
and uh we are the only party that is
really taking from both labour and the
conservatives at this point in time i
can see you shaking your head slightly
there christine jordan about her taking
seats from the label the conservatives
are you disputing that or
well i i think actually you would have
to discount to say that um the greens
were the only people taking seats from
the conservative and labor you would
have to count north shropshire and
cheshire and american by elections um
where we did quite spectacularly take
parliamentary seats and we are seeing
people coming to us right across the
country and particularly in those areas
where they're unhappy with the
conservative government which feels
completely out of touch um with the
the burdens and the challenges which
have been faced by ordinary families and
pensioners across the country and we're
seeing that in scotland we're seeing
that in the the blue wall seats in the
south of england we're seeing that up
and down the country people are
increasingly bored and annoyed and
frustrated with the attitude of
conservative government okay you think
you can already see some of the kind of
rivalry perhaps between your two parties
over uh some of those votes coming
through right let's bring in claude
cummery at this point xiao we can speak
to liz savile roberts um same question
to you what's a good night look like for
plaid camry
well interestingly we do things a little
bit different in wales because of course
we did very well in the last local
election so we're keen to keep hold of
the four councils that we already run
and we are keen of course to increase
the number of councillors but there's a
couple things i'd like to talk about one
of them is the common ground alliance
between plague emery and the green party
and cardiff where we're working together
and i'd also like to just point the
thing at wrexham as well where we have a
a strong set of female candidates
particularly going for it and wrexham
but we really are doing things
differently here in wales plague cambrie
is working with alongside welsh
government with the corporation
agreement and one of our flagship
policies will be brought in in local
authorities in september when we've
secured uh 200 million pounds extra in
this year's budget to bring on universal
free school meals for all primary school
pupils um i just want to pick you up on
that um because it is quite interesting
how you are effectively putting these
unity candidates forward the common
ground alliance is that a bit of a
reflection of the fact that pride conrad
can't win without that kind of alliance
i think you're doing it in a council
where you don't really have much
representation
well let's look at it as to what
politics is actually about if we can
bring about our policies
and improve people's lives and if you
think about a policy like free school
meals as a time of the cost of living
crisis if we can do that
then surely it's more of a question over
the old style old school adversarial
politics that we have to operate in
westminster
that's not how politics operates in the
rest of the world so if we can come
together on common policies i think
that's what people want to see and
that's what i'm being told when i go
around campusing okay let's talk a bit
more about what you are hearing on the
doorstep it's always quite interesting
to hear about the kind of issues that
people are bringing up uh christine john
dean when you're out door knocking one
of the things that people are talking
about they talk about cost of living
they talk about potholes they're talking
about partygate what is it
well three of those actually um they are
in scotland they're particularly annoyed
at the the scottish government um has
taken 250 million away from from
councils which is making their burden at
the moment much more
difficult it's making it much more
difficult for them to to do things like
keep schools up to standards to fill pot
holes in the roads but the two things
which i'm hearing most of are about the
cost of living and partygate which are
linked in people's minds now because
they see a government which seems
completely out of touch and at a time
when the rest of the country was
following the rules which the
conservative government had said which
boris johnson had set for us and was
telling us always so important they were
ignoring them and now in this cost of
living crisis when ourselves and other
parties are saying cut vat put money
back into people's pockets you know give
them the money to spend they're coming
out with nonsense about you know use
value brands
don't they think that people who are on
a limited income or a low income or even
nowadays a medium income don't already
know that so the frustration with the
conservative government is getting worse
almost on a daily basis and we are
hearing that everywhere in every part of
the country okay amelia womack what are
you hearing at most on the doorstep
so interestingly with our local
campaigns there has been a real link
between the uh failure of councils in
people's areas uh people feel like their
votes are being taken for granted and
that is also reflected in things like
the cost of living and partygate i think
you know there are no such thing as safe
seats only safe voters and what i see is
an increasing amount of people who are
no longer safe voters for for any
political party and are looking for
hardworking people who actually have
civic um duty as part of the work they
want to do in politics because they've
seen too much ego in it of course
partygate has come up and integrity has
been a key issue that people have spoken
to me about where is integrity and
politics i think it's interesting that
people are talking more about the
parties than they are at the fact that
boris johnson allegedly lied to
parliament uh which from some of the
conversations i've had just shows that
there's a lack of faith in politicians
as a result of of all of these issues
but the cost of living crisis has come
up time and time again and uh with the
opportunity to ensure that we're
investing in our communities with the
work such as the insulation schemes that
we've put in uh in lewis council were in
something that we're calling the lewis
model where we're able to insulate some
of the poorest homes to
to ensure that they're protected against
uh rise and falls in fuel prices uh
against the leaky homes that we have
that means heat consistently escapes i'm
going to have to take an opportunity to
talk about these hyper local issues that
are relevant to the
big national ones they go i'm sorry i'm
rattling through you all but i just
gotta try and make sure you all get a
last chance and i do want to have a
final one with you at liz several
roberts big issues on the doorstep
what's happening
oh the the big issues here of course
the cost of living crisis
the cost of energy particularly in our
rural areas and also very much as well
um local housing for local people i live
in a seaside village um you mentioned
the presence of the of the conservatives
and the reaction that they're getting
extraordinarily the conservatives have
put up a candidate here in my county of
gwyneth
who actually is a second homeowner and
their address is in cheshire so it gives
you a sense you know not only am i
hearing from people that in all honesty
boris johnson is now he's a source of
mockery he's not taken seriously he's a
liability on the doorstep you're gonna
have to help conservatives here and they
put somebody with a second home up gonna
happen
thank you every question very much for
all coming on the program uh today uh
three women they're hoping for your vote
uh tomorrow uh we'll have to find out
how those parties do along with uh the
rest of them as well well now the
biggest story tomorrow however it could
be in northern ireland where people are
going to be voting for members of the
national assembly in what could be a
massive change for the country's
politics poll suggests that shin fein
could be on the brink of a historic
election victory our cena island
correspondent david blevins reports
for some there's only one election issue
the brexit border separating them from
great britain
but there are other pressing concerns
even in unionist heartlands the protocol
there's no doubt that but to me the
housing issue is the the biggest issue
the biggest issue in this area i like to
say it's getting equal in quality for
both sides yes no yes and i think the
number one factor is
the living issue yeah the electric and
the gas what they do for my community
they don't do nothing for my community
they only come around the door when
they're looking their phone
irish nationalists are poised for a
historic victory but shin feins michelle
o'neill can only become first minister
if unionists form a government with her
father martin mcgill fears more
political stalemate he rebuked
politicians at journalist lira mckee's
funeral for not coming together sooner
why in god's name
does it take the death of a 29 year old
woman with her whole life in front of
her
the priest says political vacuums are
dangerous in northern ireland
i have to say my my blood would run cold
i would put it as strongly isn't that
with the idea of steel mitt
steelmate here has left us in some very
very dark places so if they're still
made that our politicians refuse to do
that then we
then they provide a ground where the
likes of those in organized crime gangs
will flourish in the last stormont
election the democratic unionist party
won 28 seats sinfin 27 but the dup is
under pressure over brexit
there are two more moderate parties the
ulster unionists and the nationalist
sdlp and alliance its middle ground vote
steadily increasing
freya mcclement's northern editor of the
irish times says a shin fian win would
write a whole new chapter here it plays
into the question of a border pole a
unity referendum whether there should be
a united ireland because that's the
conversation that was put really firmly
on the agenda by brexit that
conversation is not going away and
you'll hear the dup very vocal on this
saying if there's a nationalist first
minister it brings that border pool
closer
brexit and the resulting border in the
irish sea have been political game
changers here one driving nationalist
demands for irish unity the other
fueling unionist fears about their place
in the united kingdom and that creates
the potential for this to be a defining
election
for a hundred years storm and elections
have been won by pro-british parties
victory for an irish nationalist party
holds out the prospect of real
constitutional change
david blevins sky news at stormont
i shall be hearing a lot more from david
blevins in the coming days about those
all-important elections in stormont
meanwhile live in westminster up next
we're going to be taking a look at some
more polling for this program to find
out some of the issues driving people's
votes tomorrow
hello welcome back live to westminster
you're watching the election special on
the take now we've got another set of uh
polling for the program so we're trying
to give you a bit of an insight into
what could happen tomorrow and
why now have a look at some of it
firstly we wanted to know what the
biggest issues were for voters so you
can see here the cost of living crisis
coming out at number one on 57
followed by uh the mhs crime and
policing and then you've got the
infamous condition of roads this is the
potholes that everyone has been talking
about on the programme tonight
next we wanted to have a look at what
voters thought of the main parties in
local government so you can see here
that the labour party are perceived to
perform slightly better in councils than
the other parties said the kind of red
section there and listening to people's
views value for money and so on but an
awful lot of people frankly don't
actually know
and then finally
this shows what people think will happen
once we have the results of tomorrow's
votes just an indication what people
think the majority of people expect a
bad night for the conservatives they're
55 saying that they think they will lose
more than win
and labour
people think just about will
do about the same or perhaps will gain
will actually end up gaining more than
they lose that's 38
uh there now that polling for the show
came from ipsos so let's talk a bit more
about the findings but it's chief
executive kelly beaver who joins us now
everyone on the program tonight has been
saying that it's all about local issues
it's about potholes do you think that's
true or what do you think are the issues
people are voting on
so the overriding issue is clearly cost
of living and that comes through not
just in the
doorstep conversations that your mp
panels were having earlier but in this
survey and the study that we have
conducted on behalf of sky news but
beneath the surface of that it's a real
mix of local and national issues sophie
and we do see local just ahead of
national in terms of what people say is
going to be important in what they vote
for issues like housing local transport
bin collections and the infamous
potholes
ahead of some of those national issues
but government performance and perceived
government performance is still in the
mix there and we see four in ten people
saying that will influence their vote
and also the perception of the national
party leaders again four intense saying
that will influence their vote tomorrow
in a local election so it is a mix but
definitely this is a local election and
local issues are definitely at the fore
talking about the national leaders there
as you did at the very first interview
on the program michelle donald said that
boss johnson is still an asset to the
conservative party at elections rather
than a liability do you think she's
right think the conservative party have
come into this particular election the
local elections with a lot of challenges
so partygate is still in the voter's
psyche and boris johnson is heavily
linked to partygate it is not in the top
issues that people are worried about but
it is still there for one in five people
that's something that they will be
voting uh voting because of and thinking
about when they come to their ballot box
um so i think boris is still linked with
some of that but on the other hand we
have seen his polling results and
people's concerns about him start to
soften and they are softening their
views on whether or not the conservative
party should change their their leaders
so there's a bit of a mixed bag there i
think when it comes to voter perceptions
of boris johnson fascinating stuff
really interesting uh to hear some of
those insights kelly bieber there from
ipsos thank you
well we've had no shortage of uh takes
on the program tonight from across the
political spectrum a real kind of rattle
through at the different parties let's
get a last thought shall we from our
deputy political editor sam coach
nearly there
um what are you going to be looking out
for in the local election son
well i think i'm going to i'm going to
make you a prediction i think by the
time we get to friday night i think
there are going to be warning lights for
both the conservatives and the labour
party i was in
uh i uh i was up in peterborough today
and it just struck me that people have
made up their mind about boris johnson
but just don't know enough about
kierstarma and looking at some of that
polling that we saw earlier in the
evening those projections i don't think
anybody's going to come away
particularly happy with the results but
i think the other thing that's going to
happen is politics is going to speed up
enormously after thursday we've got a
queen speech next week that's going to
trigger a fight with the european union
huge questions about how much treasury
money goes behind the cost of living
over the next few months you've got
inflation possibly at 15 by the autumn
energy bills at four and a half thousand
pounds a year these are things that are
inconceivable to us today ministers only
just starting to grappling with them i
think we've all got to hold on to our
seats and it's in that context that
essentially party leaders parties have
to work out whether to retain their
party leaders and perhaps you know as
you say to men who end up not quite have
done enough
to allay some of the concerns from their
party sam thank you as always big show
for us tonight that's it for the take
i'll be guiding you through the local
election coverage right here on sky news
on friday of course we'll have all the
news from northern ireland as well
coming up next up it's gone news at 10.
[Music]